all right let's move on the nfl and the
nfl players association have been
talking about a new labor deal the new
york times paints a very positive
picture of the possibility the deal will
be done sooner than later because the
nfl wants to get labor piece and then go
to the media companies and get
extensions for tv deals going beyond
2022 when the bulk of those contracts
expire it makes sense i understand it
but chris here's the reality it's one
thing to have cordial conversations when
you're checking off the issues that
there aren't a fight about but when it's
time to get down to the big issues money
and other things the the players want
the union wants that the league wants
you may hit some roadblocks and just
because it's been a smooth start it can
change at any point and look at how how
cantankerous it was back in 2011 it can
retreat to that very easily and i think
the players are the ones more likely to
go that route this time because the
league is very happy with the cba they
never complain about the current cba
they say it works for both sides which
is code 4. it really works for us and
we'd like you to think it's working for
you too yeah i mean yes hey listen i'm
all for it i hope everything works out
the right way i want it i want this to
to uh
you know move in the right direction and
and for both sides to see eye to eye i
mean come on we got football nfl it's
kind of go it's going in the right
direction you know we got the last cba
done everything was skyrocketing in the
right direction then we had the you know
kneeling anthem protest football kind of
got hurt there for a little bit
rebounded and everything seems to be on
the up and up so we don't want to lose
this momentum as far as people that are
associated with the nfl but i mean to me
yeah when i look at things right away i
just go yeah this is good but uh we
haven't talked about franchise tags or
fifth year options yet or little things
like that that are truly affecting
sometimes ruining nfl players lives that
way and those are going to be some of
the nitty gritty details that yeah i
want to see how friendly this
relationship stays when they get into
some of those type of discussions
and the item in the new york times
touches on an important issue that the
union leadership would like to get a
deal done before march of 2020 when eric
winston will step aside as the president
of the nfl players association and a new
president will be elected and the new
york times doesn't venture far very far
down the rabbit hole chris but there's a
real concern both by the union and by
the league that someone could take over
as nflpa president and be far more
aggressive
far more confrontational far more
hell-bent on trying to get things that
they're just not going to be able to get
without a strike and the reality is a
strike isn't going to work but you know
it could quickly shift from
cordial to
yes some sort of a of a war footing
between the league and the union
depending upon who the next president of
the union is that gives both sides a
reason to get this deal done before
march they both have to be on the same
page about when the deadline is anytime
you've got a high stakes negotiation if
you don't have the two sides in
agreement on when you need to get the
deal done by you can't get the deal done
because nobody wants to move to their
bottom line before they have to because
if you do you get squeezed off of your
bottom line position so if they can
agree we want to get this done by march
1 because we want to be able to go get
these new tv deals and we're concerned
about who the next president of the
nflpa is let's just get it done let's
have peace and then let's go make a ton
of money and the challenge is going to
be making that all work before you know
there could be a faction of the players
who see what's what's coming and they
say we want to fight yeah we don't want
it to be cordial we don't want it to get
wrapped up quickly it's not going to be
an easy thing for the union to pull off
no i i mean the union i think is uh
more intelligent and ready for business
negotiations than ever before you know
first of all eric winston i think has
been a phenomenal leader to this point a
guy i know who i have a lot of respect
for he's fun i mean he's smart he
understands football he's there to
support the football players but yeah it
is going to be interesting to see what
the players are willing to or not to
kind of uh stand up for in this process
and to me you know i mentioned i think
the two things that are going to be you
know big talking points that's the
franchise tag and the fifth year option
those are things that bother me but
players know what's going on neither i
guarantee you neither one is going
anywhere but you could have somebody who
decides to get involved in union
leadership and try to pursue these
things that are just
essentially a waste of time because
we're never going to come up with a
compromise we're never going to give up
enough to get rid of the franchise tag
so let's not waste our time arguing
about the franchise tag let's be very
efficient in how we boil this down to
the issues where we need to have a
meaningful negotiation and the challenge
in any negotiation you have to have both
sides understanding each other and
speaking the same language and if you
have one side trying to be cooperative
and the other side trying to be
combative and last time around it was
the nfl trying to be combative you could
flip it this time and it makes it harder
to get a deal done is but but as long as
the union can't back it up with a strike
and i don't think they can the current
players will not give up their game
checks they will not give up the ability
to play football to help somebody who's
going to play the sport 5 10 15 years
from now no no that i mean that's
exactly it that's what we talk about it
all the time that's what this is part of
the vehicle that the franchise tag is
used on these players will just play
football they won't really fight us
they're just gonna say yes they like
playing football and they're the type of
guys who you know take coaching and want
to please the coaches and please their
teammates so yeah those are the avenues
that you know the owners have a definite
advantage over the players because yeah
players want to play football that's
what they want to do and
yeah some of those things are going to
be
pretty interesting to watch here down
the stretch of this negotiations
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports